- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is start thinking about the position
of an object traveling in one dimension.
And to get our bearings there,
I'm going to introduce a few ideas.
So the first idea is that of displacement.
So you might use that
word in everyday language,
and it literally means
your change in position,
your change in position.
Now a related idea that
sometimes get confused
with displacement is a notion of
distance traveled.
You might say well doesn't that,
isn't that just the same
thing as change in position?
And you will see shortly, no, it isn't
always the same thing.
The distance traveled, this
is the total length of path,
total length
of path.
So what are we talking about?
Well let's say, and
we're going to introduce
a little bit of calculus now,
let's say that we have a
particle's velocity function.
And so let's say our velocity
as a function of time
is equal to five minus t.
Now this is a one-dimensional
velocity function.
Let's say it's just
telling us our velocity
in the horizontal direction.
And oftentimes when
something's one dimension,
people forget well that too
can be a vector quantity.
In fact this velocity is a vector quantity
because you could think
of it if it's positive
it's moving to the right,
and if it's negative
it's moving to the left.
So it has a direction.
And so sometimes you will see
a vector quantity like this
have a little arrow on it,
or you will see it bolded,
or you will see it bolded like that.
I like to write an arrow in,
although that's not
always the convention used
in different classes.
Now let's plot what this velocity function
actually looks like,
and I did that ahead of time.
So you can see here,
at time equals zero, let's
say time is in seconds,
and our velocity's in meters per second.
So this is meters per
second right over here,
and this is seconds on this axis.
At exactly time zero,
this object is traveling
at five meters per second.
We can say to the right, it has a velocity
of positive five meters per second.
But then it keeps decelerating
at a constant rate,
so five seconds into it,
right at five seconds,
the particle has no velocity,
and then it starts
having negative velocity,
which you could interpret as
moving to the left.
So let's think about a few things.
First let's think about
what is the displacement
over the first five seconds,
over first
five seconds?
Well we've seen already multiple times,
if you wanna find the change in quantity,
you can take the integral
of the rate function of it.
And so velocity is actually
the rate of displacement
is one way to think about it.
So displacement over
the first five seconds,
we can take the integral
from zero to five,
zero to five,
of our velocity function,
of our velocity function.
Just like that.
And we can even calculate
this really fast.
That would just be this
area right over here,
which we can just use a
little bit of geometry.
This is a five by five triangle,
so five times five is 25, times 1/2,
remember area of a triangle's
1/2 base times height.
So this is going to be 12.5,
and let's see this is going
to be meters per second
times seconds, so 12.5 meters.
So that's the change in position
for that particle over
the first five seconds.
Wherever it started,
it's now going to be 12.5
meters to the right of it,
assuming that positive is to the right.
Now what about over,
over the first
10 seconds?
Now this gets interesting,
and I encourage you to pause
your video and think about it.
What would be the displacement
over the first 10 seconds?
Well we would just do the same thing,
the integral from zero to 10
of our velocity function,
our one-dimensional velocity function, dt.
And so that would be the area from here
all the way to right over there.
So this entire area.
But you might appreciate,
when you're taking a definite integral,
if we are below the t-axis
and above the function like this,
this is gonna be negative area.
And in fact this area and this area
are going to exactly cancel out,
and you're going to get zero meters.
Now you might be saying how can that be?
After 10 seconds how do we,
what why is our displacement
only zero meters?
This particle's been
moving the entire time.
Well remember what's going on.
The first five seconds,
it's moving to the right,
it's decelerating the whole time,
and then right at five seconds,
it has gone 12.5 meters to the right.
But then it starts, it's velocity
starts becoming negative,
and the particle starts
moving to the left.
And so over the next five seconds,
it actually moves 12.5 meters to the left,
and then these two things net out.
So the particle has gone
over 10 seconds 12.5 meters
to the right and then
12.5 meters to the left,
and so its change in
position is zero meters.
It has not changed.
Now you might start,
you might start to be appreciating
what the difference between displacement
and distance traveled is.
So distance,
if you're talking about
your total length of path,
you don't care as much about direction.
And so instead of thinking about velocity,
what we would do is think about speed.
And speed is,
you could view
in this case, especially in
this one-dimensional case,
this is equal to the
absolute value of velocity.
Later on when we do multiple dimensions,
it would be the magnitude
of the velocity function,
which is what the absolute function,
which is what the absolute
value function does,
in one dimension.
So what would this look
like if we plotted it?
Well the absolute value
of the velocity function
would just look like that.
And so if you want the distance,
you would find, the distance
traveled I should say,
you would find the integral
over the appropriate
change in time of the speed
function right over here,
which we have graphed.
So notice, if we want
the distance traveled,
so I'll just say I'll write it out,
distance traveled
over first five seconds,
first five seconds,
what would it be?
Well it would be the
integral from zero to five
of the absolute value of
our velocity function,
which is you can just view
it as our speed function
right over here, dt.
And so it would be this area,
which we already know to be 12.5 meters.
So for the first five seconds,
your distance and
displacement are consistent.
Well that's because you have in this case
the velocity function is positive,
so the absolute value of it
is still going to be positive.
But if you think about over
the first 10 seconds, your distance,
10 seconds,
what is it going to be?
Pause the video and try to think about it.
Well that's gonna be the
integral from zero to 10
of the absolute value of
our velocity function,
which is going to be equal to what?
It's going to be this area plus this area
right over here.
So plus this area right over here.
And so this is going to
five times five times 1/2
plus five times five times 1/2,
which is going to be 25 meters.
The particle has gone
12.5 meters to the right,
and then it goes back
12.5 meters to the left.
Your displacement, your net
change in position is a zero,
but the total length of path traveled
is 25 meters.